apples been working on Sirius since long
before Amazon or Google had these
digital assistants but serious phone
behind in the last couple of years it's
just not good enough it just doesn't do
enough things so today at WWDC in there
Apple made the biggest changes to Siri
since it launched Siri but now an iOS 10
series going to be able to do so much
more there are two big things first of
all Siri is now everywhere series on the
iPhone but it's also on the Mac now
where it can search for files or send
messages or add calendar events it's
also improved on the Apple TV where it
can do more more powerful searches its
in-car play in your car series designed
to be really your primary interface to
every Apple device going forward the
other part is Siri is now open to people
it's never had access to before say if
your uber now you can develop for series
so that when I say Siri call me a ride
it can go straight through uber you can
use Siri now to send payments send
messages through things that aren't just
a messages app lots and lots of things
this is what Apple is smart to do is
open it up and say we have this cool
technology you figure out what to do
with it and that's what developers have
been wanting to do for years and it's
what they get to do now it feels like
Siri might have a real shot for the
first time in a long time